all right we got one quick debate club
to close it out we've been keeping with
school theme yeah what's up Ted it's not
Brandon Brennan you look like an umpire
at an adult softball league game and
Theo
I saw you in Amsterdam walking on the
side of the street we crossed paths
I said gang gang you said what's up so I
just want to say thanks for that I don't
know if he remembered we spoken
Instagram but anyways you guys remember
that he's asking you dude what did he
ask me do you remember do you remember
talk to him on Instagram I don't know I
thought he said I stole him let's out of
the street he said that too but then he
said like you can't eat talk to you
about an Instagram
oh no the man that I saw was all working
for post mates I think his name was
William that might be him no this man
was blond-headed unless he shaved his
head it could've been commercially yes I
do remember brother when you were in
school did you one strap the backpack or
did you to strap it Bret I don't know
you have more experience in this cuz
Theo you were homeschooled for your old
life but you know anyway our backpacks
brother good to see you again dude
I do want to say that and I do remember
this beautiful guy dude and he wrote
this little thick piece laying slimfast
inside the road in Amsterdam
yeah I'm slinging out those slim slows
and slippery Oh
once one or two in college I went to in
high school I went one be cool let me
think about that college you went to in
college the books were [ __ ] heavy
dude
books forever yeah you couldn't go ten
to one yeah one in high school was a
little bit more like hey I'm gonna kill
myself
what look at me you know kind of do the
depression like oh man oh not my hair in
your face No
no no once taught in high school man I'm
down to do something yeah yeah to meant
you were door trying to get some stats
you know - in high school yeah was dorky
- in high school was dorky doing College
made sense though the books are so heavy
but then they always had like we had
this the biggest guy like guy at our
school that's got TJ Moen he used to
wear two straps and he was like a big
tough dude so he gonna do whatever I
think also depending on who you were who
you know but he also had no books in his
book bag either which was also screams
y'all that's all I did
I remember opened his book and I wanted
to have like seven pencils did you ever
wear overalls because if you left one of
those you leave one off like you're
criss cross if you stop in the middle of
gangster that's gay bro one overall one
overall yeah and then the girls are
doing that the tips oh that's sexy bro
yeah that's sexy if I see a girl in
overalls dude game on we get in under
all's that's sex bro what would the fan
say 80% said to strap it yeah yeah - so
I think it's definitely - sure I got
that JanSport or that North Face got to
do two straps done it's all about
business these days do did you ever have
where your book bag distract him with
running you had to [ __ ] sew it back
up and it was plastic and that [ __ ]
would get all ready and then get it tie
it [ __ ] together what's the hot thing
on the streets now with backpacks or
JanSport still in I think it's just no
education I think yeah you see a lot of
kids can't even learn early kids just
take their tablets everywhere now yeah
they used to make us buy that we
remember the whole [ __ ] Ponzi scheme
those math teachers with the ti-83 the
Texas Instrument when those things came
out they blew regular calculators out of
the watch you could play video games on
it yeah well in what do you movie that
was algebra first of all you're talking
about and you download games on the
ti-83 really yep that's why everyone's
all crunk about them oh I never did that
I remember the up but with like the
old-school calculation you could write
something and turn backwards spelled
boobies
he was eight zero zero eight one three
five
I know Steel's boobies six nine two two
two five one times eight spells boobless
yeah like you guys are doing real well
with you passing you afraid like yeah
guys like a yeah well hopefully we helps
people
[Music]